اذا ضعف او ارهاق عسكري على الاقل يشكو
منه الجانبان الاوكراني والروسي وفق
الوثائق الامريكيه المسربه وثائق
البنتاجون كشفت مدى عمق اختراق الولايات
المتحده لاجهزه الامن والاستخبارات
الروسيه اختراق استخباراتي سهل لواشنطن
تمريره معلومات مهمه الى اوكرانيا حول
كيفيه الدفاع عن نفسها حيث حضرتها بشكل
يومي بشان توقيت ضربات موسكو المخطط لها
واهدافها المحدده وكذلك تقديم تقييم لقوه
اله الحرب الروسيه وفقا اللواشنطن بوست
الوثائق صورت الجيش الروسي على انه منهك
في حربه في اوكرانيا ووصفته بالجهاز
العسكري المعرض لخطر كبير التقليم
الامريكي لم يظهر الجيش الاوكراني بوضع
افضل
حاله ان يرثى لها مع نقص حاد ومقلق في
ذخائر الدفاع الجوي الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه تكافح لمجارات الصواريخ
الروسيه وفقا لاحدى الوثائق قدره اوكرانيا
على توفير دفاع جوي متوسط المدى لحمايه
الخطوط الاماميه
ستنخفض تماما بحلول 23 من مايو مقبل
محللون عسكريون ارجحوا تاثير التسريب سلبا
على ساحه المعركه والحاقه اضرارا كبيرا
بجهود اوكرانيا الحربيه من خلال منح موسكو
فرصه محتمله لقطع مصادر المعلومات
الوثائق المسربه من البانتاجون تكشف
معطيات صادمه
توقل امريكي كبير في الجهاز العسكري
الروسي والاوكراني
[موسيقى]
الوثائق اظهرت قدره واشنطن على تحذير
اوكرانيا بشان الضربات المخطط لها من
روسيا وتقييم اله الحرب الروسيه
الوثائق ترسم صوره للجيش الروسي المتهاوي
الذي يكافح في حرب اوكرانيا
وتكشف نقل المعلومات الحساسه للدفاع عن
نفسها من خلال تحديد توقيت الضربات
واهدافها
الوثائق تظهر ان عملاء واشنطن يخترقون
تقريبا كل الاجهزه الامنيه الروسيه
مسؤول استخباراتي غربي قال ان التسريب
مؤلم وقد يحد من تبادل المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات